hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 21 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet always fun to see the calculator
back got the big WTF tease at the end
which is kind of where I think the all
of our characters had it they had that
big explainer last week about how Oliver
can counter his magic sort of there's a
version of this where Oliver can channel
light magic so it just seems like we're
headed for magical Oliver in the finale
like some big moment where he channels
some big magic even if he doesn't
actually gain magical powers I'm sure
Stephen Amell would like to do that but
he seems pretty set on the character
staying grounded
so usually Oliver is the character
reacting so like all the crazy magical
characters around him so that's kind of
like the funny WTF reaction at the end
we're gonna need a bigger arrow so top 5
WTF and Easter eggs there were a couple
Easter eggs I've talked about the
monument point Easter Egg a couple times
in videos this year it's the storyline
that Marc Guggenheim the showrunner from
arrow wrote for just a society right
before flashpoint like he basically
closed down just to society before they
rebooted everything for flashpoint so
Monument Point was a big part of that
arc for number 5 Haven rock gets wiped
off the map so there were a couple
differences from the comic book
storyline they were really just
borrowing the name but in that storyline
there's a bunch of bombs placed all over
the city by the villain that Justice
Society has to stop them from going off
part of the city blows up anyway they
end up fixing it Jay Garrick becomes the
mayor and all's better but he absorbed
the souls of tens of thousands of people
as opposed to the millions of people
that were in Monument Point so number 4
WTF they have to get help from
calculator always fun to see him back
now he's a birds of prey character but
they don't really have like all the
birds of prey characters on the TV show
so maybe in future seasons if they bring
the new black canary back and they they
like they actually make her the black
canary that's kind of where it seemed
like they were headed with that
character when they introduced her and
she was able to mod the canary cry for
herself but that's all season 5 stuff
he's definitely in next week's episode
but I don't know if he's also in the
finale but one of my favorite moments it
was kind of a throwaway moment but it
was still pretty funny when she almost
runs him over with the van Oliver has
his beau Felicity has her van number 3
though is the Baron Rider fight in the
flashbacks that was a lot of fun just
him soaking damaged like he's taking
some giant raid fight so if you forgot
they actually did the same thing to
damian darhk-- they just started filling
full of all kinds of bullets in the
strength that they gained from the totem
is limited there's like a certain
quantity so the more damage you soak the
more energy it drains that's why they
have to keep killing people to refill
the tank but we also saw the scene with
Tiana with like the glowy eyes last week
when Oliver was learning about the magic
they played this greatest hits real
there was a scene from this week's
episode when he said something bad had
happened in the past to one of his
friends because of one of these idols
when he was talking to the shaman last
week I'm wondering if that means that
she gets corrupted by dark magic and
ends up dying but you can kind of see
where they're headed with these
flashbacks you know like once they get
away with the idol they're probably
going to be headed for Russia because I
think that's where the season 5
flashbacks are supposed to take place
number 2 Vinnie Jones is back is brick
felicity had the nice Greatest Hits line
for season 3 just the writers making fun
of themselves but if you remember his
power is that he just has super strong
skin he's kind of like Luke Cage without
super strength but I actually liked
anarchy scenes who is also back with
Thea even though I think they had some
pacing issues between the Thea scenes
between the team arrow scenes and
between the flashback scenes the wait
Thea played it made me feel like Alex is
dead I was never a big fan of his
character but it's always interesting to
see the show bring on notable actors
just to see how they might use them
usually there's some expectation of
secret identity like any time they bring
on a name actor you're like I wonder if
this is gonna be somebody from the
comics so I feel like he had a couple
good moments when they were doing the
campaign storyline but after that I
wasn't really a big fan of Thea's scenes
with him I think there are a couple
characters they brought on this season
to fill out other characters backstories
like you have Oliver and all these
characters around him but then when you
want to develop other characters like
Diggle you bring in Lyla you have babies
Sara so you kind of have to do that for
all the other characters too
the Alex character was there to give
them more room for the Thea character to
grow they brought in both Felicity's
parents for similar reasons just to give
her character more room to grow number
one WTF of course damian darhk--
absorbing all the souls from Haven rock
so now he really is the big bad if you
guys don't know if with the term big bad
means it's just a way of describing the
main villain of a series this of
comparable strength to the hero so he
and the hero go back and forth that at
some point in the story he gains some
artifact or some power and becomes the
big bad someone who is too
our full for the hero to fight so the
hero has to rise to their level by
gaining some special power or learning
some secret knowledge or something like
that so that's why we've been seeing all
this super magical Oliver stuff like
Oliver will have to rise to damien
darhk's level in order to counter his
magic but they did say in the finale
he's going to get help from a surprising
force so I'm wondering if that's gonna
be Constantine but I'll be interested to
see how they stick the landing I feel
like the flash was pretty good this week
there are a couple episodes where the
pacing was off and some of their logic
was a little fuzzy so it was really nice
that this week's episode worked out
arrows kind of had the same problem so
I'll be really interested to see how
they resolve the plot but if you didn't
know there are two more episodes of
arrow same for the flash to all the
finales will air during the same week
and the same goes for legends of
tomorrow and there is a new legends of
tomorrow on Thursday if you haven't seen
it yet I did start a new round of the
giveaway in my flash video that'll just
stay open for the rest of the week cuz
I'll do a couple more DC videos but let
me know in the comments what do you
think they're talking about when they
say Oliver's gonna get help from a
surprise force do you think it's a
person like Constantine or do you think
it's some magical twist like one of his
tattoos it would be a really nice
surprise for them to bring Constantine
back for the finale but I haven't heard
any rumors or seen anything special
about that I am working on a new Voltron
video while you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for this week's
episode of the flash and you can click
here to catch up on Game of Thrones
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you